the economic costs of coronavirus are
mounting everywhere with the squeeze on
international travel affecting Airlines
in particular the German carrier
Lufthansa has grounded hundreds of
planes and for UK regional carrier fly B
it was all too much the already
struggling airline succumbed to
bankruptcy and it may not be the last
cruise operators will also be suffering
thousands of passengers are stranded
aboard the Grand Princess off the coast
of California as tests are carried out
on board the vessel belongs to the same
company that owned the virus stricken
Diamond Princess held off the Japanese
Coast last month with 700 cases on board
and six deaths as coronavirus increases
its reach with South Africa registering
its first case and the UK and
Switzerland their first fatalities each
day brings heightened levels of response
that the World Health Organization says
it's concerned some countries aren't
taking the threat seriously enough this
is not a time of for excuses this is a
time for pulling out all the stops
countries have been planning for
scenarios like this for decades now is
the time to act on those plans the
presence of community transmission means
efforts to contain the disease are
failing
money is being thrown at the problem in
the United States with Congress
approving an eight billion dollar war
chest the International Monetary Fund
says it's making fifty billion dollars
available in aid to low-income and
emerging market countries to fight the
epidemic but economic gloom with the
rising threat of recession has brought
some glimmers of opportunity one
ecommerce firm in South Korea said it
was struggling to keep pace with demand
as shoppers desert the streets and move
online in the past we used to go out
with the truck half full but these days
there's so much to deliver there are
packages left over after filling the
truck completely elsewhere the retreat
of
whole communities into isolation
continues in Bethlehem Palestinian
officials have closed the Church of the
Nativity weeks before the Easter season
that draws tens of thousands of visitors
and worshipers to the traditional
birthplace of Christ Italian schools
didn't open on Thursday and won't for
some time to come
similar scenes in India Iran France and
Japan in all around 300 million students
in more than 20 countries faced weeks of
disruption desperate measures in what
feel too many like desperate times when
this emergency is over we will look back
and I am convinced that we will be proud
of how an entire country has faced this
with courage and determination for now
though this emergency is just getting
started
Jonah hull al Jazeera